J'ai rencontré Dean pour la première fois peu de temps après la
mort de mon père, j'étais un jeune cavalier essayant
de décoller si Dean venait d'élever dans la
société, il venait d'épouser une
nana de 16 ans nommée Mary Lou, comment trouvez-vous
un peuple aussi merveilleux que je n'ai
jamais vu  quelqu'un comme ne fais rien que
je veux
devenir doyen Moriarty a commencé la partie
de ma vie que vous pourriez appeler ma vie sur la
route
vous avez finalement pris cette ancienne route ne
se sent pas responsable envers les autres
les bricoleurs passent un sacré bon moment juste à
être  lui-même donne des illusions
Treach je ne veux jamais te voir
je ne sais pas ce qui ne va pas avec moi faire toutes
ces bêtises et je pense que toutes ces
manières déformées
je vais rire comme d'habitude j'ai fait
toute ma vie après les gens qui
m'intéressaient comme le seul  les gens qui
m'intéressent les fous ceux qui
étaient fous de vivre fous de parler désireux
tout en même temps celui en a
dit tu veux voir une
chose banale mais brûler brûler brûler comme des bougies romaines à
travers la nuit